speaking of liars and actors we got to
talk about fauci
because now fauci is coming out
and he's kinda into this idea that the
cdc
and remember the center for disease
control it doesn't set law it can give
recommendations
but people seem to think if the cdc says
something you have to do it
uh the cdc you know they give the basic
ideas guys this is what we're seeing
this is what we think you should do this
is sort of a mandate but you don't
have to do it it's not a law as far as i
know i'm just
i'm just a simple guy um but
cdc is sort of into this idea now that
if you've been vaccinated
you probably should still wear a mask
we've got the video tape dr fauci
the cdc is saying that this is based on
new science new data
uh showing that even those who are
vaccinated
can carry the virus with them they can
be contagious
this seems to contradict what we've been
told that
once you get vaccinated you're protected
well in
in some respects yes but what's changed
duty is the virus has changed
so when you have vaccinated people who
might have a breakthrough infection and
we
know now as a fact as a scientific fact
that they can transmit the virus to an
uninfected person
it's for that reason that the cdc made
the change in recommendation
and did just as you correctly stated
namely that if you are vaccinated
if you are an indoor setting you should
still wear a mask
i hear you saying it is based on science
but
to many americans who are by now
pandemic weary
um do you understand why they may be
looking at this and we're hearing this
from some
uh from a number of americans saying
well why did
why did the cdc uh change the guidelines
two months ago
were they did they jump the gun when
they did that or they're asking you know
why weren't they more transparent
in the beginning people are asking these
kinds of questions those are reasonable
questions
judy but i think what we all need to
realizing we are dealing
with an evasive type of in a virus it
it evolves so that people need to
understand
it it's a it's a painful realization
but it's true yeah the painful
realization here anthony
is that this thing does evolve and you
guys have flip-flopped every which way
and done roughly four trillion things
that have not
helped uh two interesting pieces before
we show you this incredible video of
fouchy's flip-flops
um when everybody was pushing the
vaccine a couple months back
were they saying was there any hint that
oh guys you're going to get the vaccine
and by the way
you'll probably still get covid you'll
still be able to get covered you'll
still be able to transmit covid you're
probably gonna have to get
booster shots and by the way the whole
thing keeps
uh mutating and changing and everything
else so we'll see what happens in six
months that's not really the way they
did the sale did they actually the way
they did the sale you know i'm gonna
switch something here we're gonna do the
biden video next all right
the way they did the sale was basically
get the vaccine
and you are good to go okay and uh guess
what we got video on that too here's joe
biden
on what happens when you get the vaccine
if you are
fully vaccinated you no longer need to
wear a mask
really joe because that's not what the
cdc is saying now that's not what
fauci's saying now
so when you said that you know basically
two months ago
a month and a half ago why didn't you
say oh well
unless the science changes and morphs
which by the way fauci saying science
constantly changes and morphs and we get
new information which of course that
actually
is true i mean it's actually quite
extraordinary so now we're going to show
you
a two-minute video this went bananas
viral on
uh twitter yesterday these are just
incredible
back-and-forth compilations of fouchy
flip-flopping take a look
people should not be walking around with
masks let me just state
for the record that masks are not
theater wearing a mask might make people
feel a little bit better and masks are
protective
and but it's not providing the perfect
protection that people think
that it is there has not been any
indication
that putting a mask on and wearing a
mask for a considerable period of time
has any deleterious effects there are
unintended consequences people keep
fiddling with the mask and they keep
touching their face
and can you get some schmutz sort of
staying inside there of course
you do not need to wear a mask indoors
if in fact
you've been vaccinated good that you're
vaccinated but in a situation
where you have people indoors
particularly crowded you should wear a
mask
so even if you are vaccinated you should
wear a mask
if in fact you are vaccinated fully
vaccinated you are protected
and you do not need to wear a mask
outdoors or indoors when the children go
out
into the community you want them to
continue to wear masks you know if you
look at
children outside particularly when
they're with the family of
walking down the street playing a game
or what have you don't have to wear
a mask the the the pediatric the academy
of pediatric
actually makes that recommendation that
children should be wearing masks
uh from two years old onward and you're
asking now if
your child is a member of your household
can you walk outdoors
with your child without a mask according
to that chart
the answer is yes but the child can't
not to beat it
and beat it to death yes yes because now
the cdc says
i mean i think i've got this right one
mask is better than zero masks
two masks is better than one mask but
you don't have to have double masks
is that right i mean you know it became
clear that cloth coverings
that you didn't have to buy in a store
that you could make yourself
were adequate and then you wanted to fit
better so one of the ways you could do
it if you would like to
is put a cloth mask over which actually
here and here and here where you can get
leakage in
is much better contained are you a
double master dr
fauci look like you are we should have
played the looney tunes theme song in
the background of that thing i mean tell
me that is not
absolutely incredible and are you gonna
tell me also
that oh the science was changing the
whole time in that last year and a half
while he was doing that
that you know when you touch your face
more because the mask that actually
causes a problem is that not a problem
anymore now that they want masks on us
again
and he also says mask might make you
feel better right
because they don't do anything now mask
again even though you're vaccinated
anthony fauci if you're watching this
show i am but a humble youtuber
but i have a recommendation for you
retire